♫ Hey
♫ Time to stand together
♫ Like once before
♫ And this time we'll stop the war
(speaking Arabic)
♫ I'm in the magic business
♫ The somewhat tragic business
- I'm from Saudi Arabia
and I live in Los Angeles California.
I love music because when I perform
it feels so free.
♫ He said he was a danger
♫ He ruined his last name
♫ His daughter she's a singer
♫ Put her family to shame.
I grew up in a more
conservative society and
music is not really seen as a career
from where I come from.
It's scary you know, when you
put yourself out there and
you come from a place
where it's not typical
to put yourself out there,
especially being a woman;
that's why I wrote Gender Game.
♫ If I say my name or I show
my face I should be ashamed
And so I see myself as a bridge
between people's perceptions
of the Middle East
and people's perceptions of the West.
There are so many positive
things that are happening
in Saudi with women.
Women can now vote in
the municipal elections.
More women are working
and they're independent.
Women can't drive yet, but I do have hope
and I know that it's gonna happen soon.
We need to remember that
when we're thinking about
somebody else, when we don't
like what another culture
is doing, we need to take
a step back and remember
that we're all human beings.